[MUSIC PLAYING]
SILVANO LUCIANI:
Hi, everybody.
Welcome back to Google+
Developers Live.
I'm Silvano Luciani, and I'm a
developer programs engineer
for the Google+ platform.
JONATHAN BERI: And I'm Jonathan
Beri, a developer
advocate on Google+.
Today, we're going to talk about
some new features we
introduced to the Hangout apps
platform to create a better
developer experience, and making
it easier to develop
Hangout apps.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
So my favorite is that we
changed the way you can run
and test apps under
development.
You would now be able to share
your apps in a normal hangout,
right, Jonathan?
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
So let's take a look at the
new developer experience.
So Silvano's going to
start up a Hangout.
We actually have a new shortcut
to make it even
easier to start a Hangout.
Go to hangouts.google.com/start,
and
that will fire up a Hangout, so
you don't even need to go
through chat and invite somebody
in the beginning.
But he's actually going to go
ahead and include me in here,
and I'm going to hop on board.
So as that's getting sent over
to me, I'm going to get that
notification and jump on in.
Silvano has an app that we
developed that he is a
developer on and I'm not.
I'm just a normal Hangout
participant.
And so when he fires that up,
the way to start that app is
even easier than before.
Instead of going to the
developer console to find the
link to the Hangout, you can go
to the Add App button, and
there's a tab there where you
can find all the apps that
you're developing, whether
you're the owner and creator,
or if somebody has added you
to a project to start
developing a Hangout app.
Just going to fire that up.
Right now, you guys can't see my
screen, but I can't see the
app that he's showing on the
screen, because, again, I
don't have permission.
There's a button to share that
to everybody in the Hangout,
and I can start using
it, even though I've
never used it before.
Cool.
So now I'm in there, and you can
see my name is showing up
there, because I'm running
the app for this session.
With this experience, you can
quickly enable people to come
in and test your app quickly and
easily, and it's only for
the session.
So when I leave this Hangout,
I can't go ahead and muck
around with the app, and Silvano
can go ahead and tweak
it further.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And if, for
example, you're hanging out
with friends, and you have an
app you're currently working
on, and you want to get some
feedback from them, it's as
easy as one click, share with
them, see what they think
about, get the feedback, and
go back working on the app.
JONATHAN BERI: And then to
publish that app, it's the
same as before.
You go through the developer
console, and you can make that
app publicly available to
all the other users.
The next big thing that we
announced at Google I/O and
that we're actively working
on is a new release flow.
We have two release channels--
stable and beta.
So with the stable channel,
these are APIs that you can
use in production today for
published apps, and users can
start taking advantage of.
And it's very similar to
what we had today.
When we released an API, it
is currently available.
We introduced a new channel--
a beta channel--
that allows us to iterate more
quickly, releasing early APIs
to get developer feedback.
So Silvano, let's see some of
those features from the new
beta channel.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
So the first one is the
possibility of adding blur to
the background.
In this sample app, I have the
bottom blur my room, and then
with the slider, I can, as you
see, change the window size of
the blur to make it more
or less strong.
And this is one of the first
features that we added to the
development channel.
So remember, this is not
available for apps that are
publicly available.
You can use it only on apps
under development.
Another feature that we added
is the [INAUDIBLE].
So we added to the simple game
that will allow you to catch
the Chrome with you hand, and
now, as you see, it's catched,
and it's in my hand.
I'll just show you the
code for this.
It's very easy.
For the blur, you just need to
create a background blur
object, and you can do it
by calling gapi.hangout.
av.effects.creat
ebackgroundblur(); and then
just set the blur window size.
And what you've seen in the app
is just a slider that is
updating the sides of
the blur window.
For the hand tracking, what you
can do is add a listener
to the on hand tracking
data changed event.
This will be called every time
the hand is detected, and the
position of the hand change.
And, for example, in this
function update hand position,
we can check what happens.
We check on the event if there
is a hand detected, and if the
hand is detected, we get the
position of the center.
Then we have other functions in
the game that are actually
comparing the position of the
hand with the Chrome logo, and
understanding it fits in
the range of the hand.
One thing that I want to show
to you is there is only one
hand that is tracked on the
screen at the moment, and you
can see we can do things
like this.
But the Chrome would be always
stay on one hand.
JONATHAN BERI: Now, that API
looks very similar to the
other effects APIs
that we have.
Is that a final API?
How is that documented?
Where can we learn more
about those APIs?
SILVANO LUCIANI: So you can find
docs on the dev channel
at developers.googl
e.com/plus/hangouts/api-dev.
These docs are always evolving,
because these apps--
the apps in the development
channel--
are under development.
So if you're using these APIs,
come back often to check if we
made any changes.
And we also we really want you
to use these APIs, and we
really want you to provide us
with feedback, and you can do
it by using our issue tracker
in the developers community.
JONATHAN BERI: And we also
really want to engage with
developers to learn early,
and about their
feedback on these APIs.
So we want you to use the
Google+ community we have for
the Google+ developers'
platform, especially using the
Hangouts category.
And that's where you can come
and provide feedback, what you
think about the API design,
features that we're missing,
and other features
you want to see.
And not only is it us, the
Google Developer Relations
team working on Google+, but the
engineering team is also
in there hearing your feedback,
responding to your
questions to make the
product better.
So really engage
with us there.
And if you have issues, we also
we have a tag on Stack
Overflow that we actively
monitor, whether it's for our
Hangout apps, or other features
of the Google+ Platform.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And the
tag is Google-+.
JONATHAN BERI: Google-+.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And
also, I already
mentioned the issue tracker.
So if you're using this
development API, and you have
any suggestions for improvement
or feedback on the
usage, please use our
issue tracker.
But also, if you have general
bugs, or feature requests
about the Hangouts API or any
other of the Google+ platform
functionalities, please
use the issue tracker.
And also star issues and feature
requests, because we
use the number of stars
for each of those to
prioritize our work.
So I think that's
all for today.
Come back next Tuesday.
We will be here again with a new
super interesting topic on
the Google+ platform.
JONATHAN BERI: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]